CIRCLES.
RIPS IT HOPE IS AST TOO BIG.
THE HEE
EXTENDED LEFT.
THERE IS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY.
THE DEFENSEMEN ARE DOWN LOW
MAKING  MUCH
FUN.
PETE, MOSE, I LOVE YOU GUYS.
MISS YOU.
OVER VANCOUVER.
SHOT.
HE IS UNDERSTANDING THE PLAY.
HE POKES THECOMPHER.
THE KEY ISA
COYOTE A PAST THE LEGS OF
DEMKO. BOUNCING
PUCK.
CATCHING GLOVE OF DEMKO.
THE SECOND GOAL O OO COME ALL T.
THAT GIVES HR BRINGS IT  BACK. .
DOWN BY DEFLECTED BUT
DEVON TOEWSO
AVALANCHE ARE JUST DOING IT.
G
>> Marc: SCORE BY VANCOUVER.
IT
MORE ROAD GAMES.
>> Marc: PARTIAL CHANGE.
JOST DEEP INTO THETOGETHER.
THEY HAD
TO THE NEAR SIDE FOR BURAKOVSKY.
AFTER 11 GAMES I DON'T
FAR SIDE.
SHOOTS. PUCK COMES BACK AND BAT
OUT O